there's always a moment where you're
just doing it because you're doing it
and then you kind of realize wait is
this something big
like this is something something's
happening
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vayner nation what's good it's me gary
and i'm extremely excited
especially for my one of my best best
best
best friends in college rob muse who
within the first 48 hours of being at
mount ida college
i went to his dorm room to play madden
and he put on too short
and he banged it heavy and he was
bringing that flavor
so moose the show's for you he
short thank you so much for being on as
a
as i was just telling e before we
started this show
i was born in the soviet union but i
moved to queens and grew up in jersey
and i'm 45 so what you two men
represent to me personally you know
growing up
and being affected by hip-hop uh
and then especially in college where the
friend i just mentioned rob muse i had
friends that were really deep
into it and the education went to a
whole different place of
music just outside of just new york for
me my best friend one of my best friends
dustin bingham was from l.a
and we we when i think of you guys it
takes me to a real special time in my
life
we'll get into that in a minute but
there's a whole different thing that i
want to talk about which is
the you know the entrepreneurial journey
that i've been on
watching the entrepreneurship that's
come out of y'all
is also just been incredible and then
just modern technology
you know and the culture and the brand
building and
obviously culminating in the versus
battle for a lot of people but
i just there's i'm so [ __ ] busy these
days
so when things come across my desk of
like well you do this podcast
even real fancy fancy people i'm like i
just can't i'm too operating right now
i'm too too busy
but they didn't like i read one
word in the email they sent me about
this and i was like confirmed get it
done
asap so gentlemen thank you so much i
truly say this for my soul
you gentlemen are legends i'm honored i
will look back at this my whole life
i'm going to send the 80 clips of this
to all my boys i grew up with
i'm real happy how are you thank you
thank you for having us gary
of course for for the small group of
people that don't know
who you are e start us off give
everybody a little context of you a
little
30 45 second bios same with you short
after it and we'll we'll get into this
hey everybody what's going on i go by
the name of e40 real name earl stephens
um came in the game 1988 um first album
came out ep
most valuable players me and my family
um d-shot
sugar t be legit we became the click
a year later and um here i am now
20 21 doing my thing you know what i'm
saying uh
platinum platinum recording artist the
whole while very legendary
you know and uh my other legendary
partner he right here by me so
go ahead and identify yourself too short
yeah my name is too
short and you know for anybody who never
really knows me i just say
regardless if you could find that one
thing that identifies you to me
uh you don't have to i am ingrained in
pop culture's dna
i am very you hear me coming from 15
different angles
and whether it's my voice or another
voice and i'm just there i've been there
a long time i've sold
millions and millions of records and
i mean e40 we like homegrown bay area
and just you know we we we actually
aren't just
rappers or artists we are
two pioneers who actually laid the
foundation for a
entire region's hip hip-hop
existence let's talk let's talk about
that sure because i fully see it that
way and then i always think about
what's the foundation of the foundation
yeah right and so i want you know i had
ll on on the show a couple months ago
and just wanted to like educate all the
you know
so many youngsters listen to this and
i've been so happy with what's been
going on
and you know timbo knows got like ver
like i just
love that people get re-educated or
educated because sometimes it's both
the bay area is lucky let me give a
little look
a little bit please the area got lucky
as [ __ ] because
the bay area got in the early infancy
stages of hip-hop
it got too short and it got e40 todd
shaw
and earl stephens these were two guys
who were
we just had a dream we wanted to get we
want to get the music but
we fortunately it's that right place at
the right time thing
forty standing there in the presence of
his uncle saint charles
who has the knowledge of how to make and
sell music
i end up in the presence of dean hodges
who's
bartering all these musicians and
singers and
you know studios and all these people to
to satisfy
his personal fantasy of wanting to be in
the music industry but he
he didn't have the talent so he
surrounded himself with it and
he learned the game and he taught it to
me he taught me how to
make and sell records so at the same
time
we're getting the same sort of
information
and getting ready to put it to work
because we're both talented me and e40
we about to put this knowledge to work
but the beautiful part is we're not we
didn't just end up doing it for
us we ended up doing it for the whole
[ __ ] bay area and then we end up
almost like partners this is crazy
how did how did both of you individually
when did your music
journey career not career journey excuse
me
start in the house what was being played
what was grandma playing what was your
best friend playing like
when i say earliest music impact
where do you go with like oh i like this
where do both of you go e um
my goal from my mom being in the
church choir and being surrounded by
just so much talent my aunties playing
the drums aunties playing the drums
playing the piano you know like
naturally they never took lessons or
nothing they just
all new they all talented my uncles
um also you know being there with my um
and my earlier day my mom my dad
divorced but even so
when i was younger my daddy here being
there you know because he paint hella
good he paint cars all that he held a
talented
and my mama's so hella good she was
doing tire covers for the vans back in
the days my
daddy paint all the uh the the vans and
and the crest when i this when i stayed
in the crest
and um you know they had band clubs with
the cb the cbs and everything breaker
breaker one two and all that stuff
that's the oh all they played him and my
mama that's all they played was like the
oj's
players uh you know um um the eisley
brothers
you know just all like you know even
even even a lot of disco music like
donna summers and stuff
how old are you who me i'm 53.
yes of course that's heavy influence
disco
you know you're you know i'm 45 yeah
exactly i mean that's
you know in and lingering out but like
that's heavy influence
yeah oh yeah for sure and so you know
that then when i heard this
i'll just go fast forwarding and when i
heard the sugar hill gang
in 1979 i said i feel to be a rapper man
is that flat out you heard sugar and
flat out you said i'm gonna be a rapper
you know just
goofing around with it i got you know
i'm putting that now into 88 like
real official music in 88 but i'm saying
79
i'm just a little kid i'm only 11. you
know what i'm saying but it hit you
did you skip the marching band the band
band class
oh oh man thank you bro oh when i was in
the fourth grade i signed up for the
marching band
for the band so uh i told my mama they
say because i was in class and they was
like
anybody who want to sign up for band you
know write your name on here and we're
going to tell you what to get so they
told me to go get
they put it they gave me a little a
little list to put in there say
drum pads uh a drum a music book
and some drunk two-pair drumsticks
so i took it to my momma and i said i
want to be in bed
mom you know what i'm saying she took me
down to monash music in vallejo
you know what i'm saying and bought me
the drum two-pair drum sticks
a drum pad where you can do the you know
practice your roll the rim taps and all
that you know what i'm saying whatever
you want to call it it did
so it was it was always there yeah and i
played the drums all the way from the
fourth grade all the way to the 12th bro
like i didn't stop and you know that
wasn't so much of a cool thing to do i
was just gamed up i played all sports
all that but
that's what i did gary gary think about
it
e40 raps like a drummer drums
you know it's funny you were i was you
know i was sitting here i was like that
that
that cadence came from a hundred percent
it makes a ton of sense what about for
you short how did it like
like what did you when did you get
affected by music
so i think all of us kids who were like
if you were anywhere in that 70s
household
vibe like i don't care what color you
were
music was very like when records got big
they
they just crossed over like i play the
hits of my childhood
and then white kid from the suburb goes
those are the hits from my childhood you
know
if we're kind of close in age yep
it didn't matter like a lot of songs
when i was a kid i grew up and found out
that was a white guy that was a spanish
guy and that was you know that's right
when you actually saw them on tv fun
yeah like i would have never it was just
music so
i'm a little kid honestly
come on now that was just that was just
there on the radio it was a [ __ ]
yeah andy was going crazy
andy was the most famous person and he
found out from that little movie that
they were [ __ ] australian i didn't
know that [ __ ]
songs from anywhere from the temptations
to
raindrops keep falling on my head it was
just just music so
so i'm this little kid who i live in a
house where
they play the records they actually play
they purchase
and play records and my house
was my father's from jackson mississippi
and my mother's from a small
town outside of new orleans my house was
lots of motown before the kids had any
say so it was a lot of motown in the air
a lot of that al green kind of sold a
lot of that just in the air
i had a auntie that we used to spend a
lot of time
at her house and she took it a little
further she'd be
really like some average white band and
some
funkadelic you know album covers that we
looking at this [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
looks scary you know
she was really about music and she
wanted to collect it
she's playing this [ __ ] though she's a
little more gangster
a little more they sitting in the
kitchen
talking [ __ ] playing dominoes and cards
and that's when company would come over
and the kids
in in mild culture the kids just get
told
shut the [ __ ] up on the on the card
get your ass in the room yeah they in
there you hear all this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you
on the cards kick who's better at spades
e or short
we haven't played space but i whip short
ass in spades
i'm i'm good at everything so
one thing i know for sure i beat him in
is dominoes
he can't [ __ ] i'm a bowling expert too
um
i never see this that's what i say about
dominoes i never
talk [ __ ] and i think that there's a
certain character domino player
that the one who doesn't talk [ __ ] and
you bring that game
i'm like i don't i don't talk i never i
don't talk [ __ ] while i'm while i'm
whipping your ass i don't talk [ __ ]
i talk [ __ ] you gotta talk [ __ ] go to
the window
i need to get it i need to get to so let
me
let me tell you about the music man
because that's very specific please
i'm a traveled around kid who gets sent
to louisiana for summers and you know
spend the summer with your cousins
so i'm in this household my family's
household a lot of motown a lot of
temptations
then my um auntie is taking a little
further with the funkadelic and
we're getting some of that [ __ ] in there
then i'm down south
and my cousins they like literally this
down south where they don't even wear
shoes in the summer it's just barefoot
all day
the [ __ ] with that country and
you go into these little candy shop soda
shops but they're also the [ __ ] bar
where grown-ups hang and the kids get to
go to this one little counter
buy some candy or soda or ice cream and
get the [ __ ] out but when you go in
there they playing the grimiest
blues songs this [ __ ] is dark in the
daytime this [ __ ] is like
smokey as [ __ ] and it's just those songs
those real
dirt road blue songs i always love that
[ __ ] so
fast forward to like i'm coming of age
i'm starting to i
bought a lot of records as a kid too i
spent a lot of my candy money on records
that was kind of weird but i did it and
i am i've got to go to the george
clinton
parliament funkadelic uh 1976 mothership
connection
tour in l.a and that's the the current
the tour where he landed the mothership
on the stage
jumped out i was a gentleman i was 11 12
years old
i was i was about maybe i don't think i
was 10 and i'm like
looking at this [ __ ] like this
[ __ ] just jumped out of speed
and there were people on that show that
day like
rick james and [ __ ] it was like a whole
funk fest
and i left that day i knew i loved music
but i left that day like that
yeah that was it was just like it never
the stage
the music the individual because i
always knew how to single out
the bass player or the drummer the sound
of it the saxophone
i could just i could study the sounds
and
i was never the same i became i was
already barely a parliament fan i was
just
just getting into it about my second
album in but i just
my whole life was just like the funk
after that just died
drums too let them know you played yeah
high school right i was definitely in
the marching band i was
i was in the elementary school band for
a little while i kind of you know i just
did
i did enough in the band to learn how to
play instruments i
[ __ ] up when i got to 10th grade i
went to free my high
and i was cutting class too much and the
band teacher came to me and said
if i drop you from my class because you
only got a certain amount of days
if i drop you you can never take band
ever again and i was
i didn't say it but i was looking at him
like [ __ ] that nerd ass
[ __ ] big
biggest boy i ever made i should have
stayed in the band class
let me ask you a question in the in
did you because what you two were doing
at the time that you were doing it
and i think about like what i saw happen
at silicon valley with
social media apps i see it right now
with cryptocurrency
when you're at the beginning of
something there's always a moment where
you're just doing it because you're
doing it
and then you kind of realize wait is
this something big like this is
something something's happening
when did you realize that it was bigger
than just your pursuit of like you both
were passionate about music
young when did you realize the genre
that you found yourself in
had the potential i mean listen funk
jack i mean the fact that i'm even
saying this blows my mind jazz
like hip hop is going to go down
as one of the most foundational
genres in music history if not depends
on you know i'm not looking real long
classical right
all of it it is such a big deal you guys
have gotten to such an iconic
place you also came at a time where you
know i know enough about your career
it's like
sure you're one of the only people ever
jay-z biggie
pock to be in you know in songs with all
three like there's
you guys have done [ __ ] i actually want
to ask you a separate question soon
which is like when did you smile when
some young cat that you admired and
thought was gonna be really good or
became good
came to you and said you really impacted
my career but like
two separate questions when did you know
that it was real real real big
and that you'd be an old man and have
west coast kind of on your shoulders and
you were gonna have that class
and b any fun stories of somebody coming
up the game
saying that you really influenced them
and you can't believe how big their
career got
far as so you talking about
when somebody came up to me or just yep
i like stories i want to hear a story of
somebody coming up to you and saying
e this song made me an artist and that
person now is this because i think
people don't know history well enough
and i know there's so many young
you know listeners i always love stories
to like put things
into context yeah um this is this point
there's plenty of those
i mean it's from from the streets to the
executive suites you know what i'm
saying that like
there's so many youngsters that can tell
like this
like we could take a lo let's take a
local in a minute because this local
really is to to us somebody could he go
by the name of uh
you know jay stalin you know what i'm
saying right you know what i'm saying
um and he told me say man 40. you know
he said you know jay be talking to her
he said he said man
40 man when in a major way came out
i skipped class blood i skipped class
to go get that i skipped what
i you know i'm saying it's like this the
thing there's so many rappers
that really grew up on our music not
just mine but short as well
and they'll tell you they'll simply tell
you they will tell you
they might not tell the world but they
tell you
hey if it wasn't for you i'll be [ __ ]
up
in the street [ __ ] on the streets in
the trenches
in the octagon and they're gonna gravel
on the blacktop that'll tell you
sincerely
bruh thank you for the game thank you
because if it wasn't for you
i you know what i'm saying i don't know
how i would have made it whether they
was doing time behind them walls
or whatever the case may be because
that's all we do and to this day
we were just on the phone earlier man
sure we said we got this one song and we
ain't gonna say the concept and then we
was talking about you know it's pretty
much preaching
but it's not no it's not it's not no
preaching where it's
like too too preachy we just it's just
game and you can you can get to this you
can give to it
with a really fun hook and we're going
to slide a really powerful message
in the song well you know you know what
i think that's exactly right like when i
think about the ghetto short
like like you know for me it's
storytelling
for me right to me it's storytelling
what what both of you represent for me
i'm talking from a single person
is i like when i can see the image
it like plays like a movie in my head
there you know i'm less
around beat i know me as a consumer like
people like that beat us like i
understand like i get it
but it doesn't sink in me yeah the
artists that i really [ __ ] with
are the ones that make me feel like i'm
watching a movie
you know and especially that first album
because you had your whole life to
[ __ ] write it
you know and you're really giving me
context of you yeah those are right
right so
go ahead um
pimp c once told me that
he said um they were they they
saw the album cover to born and mack
they had never heard it too short and
they had never heard the music
they saw that album cover looked at it
held it and said
that's what i want to do for a living
we're just looking at that drop top
cadillac
and a little dude sitting there with the
jewelry man that
i'm about to do some [ __ ] like that like
that [ __ ] turned them the [ __ ] out
and they did it and they did it
something that really hit me as a writer
and a rapper and an
artist that just was outside of the
music a
friend of mine went to jail for murder
when he was 16
and i was friends with his brother i
didn't even really know him
at the time probably had been around him
but i more knew his big brother
and he came home at the age of maybe
40 42 somewhere there
and he said one day he got me one-on-one
because as soon as he came home he came
amongst the friends i was running with
at the time and he's right there and he
like one of his first days home he took
him to a too short concert and he's like
holy [ __ ]
and and he said to me he got me
one-on-one he said man you know
he said when i was down he said i went
to jail when i was a kid
he said i was a child he was 16. he said
um
i literally lived my life i lived in
oakland
through your songs
like he had no i he like man
the first person i'm too short and just
visualize what i was saying
and got to be in oakland through the
music so
i you know it's things like that that
that
make you realize the impact that you're
having like
somebody going man i launched a career
just looking at
a album cover and somebody going i
listened to your music and got through
my childhood [ __ ] young adult life in
prison
i got an outlet that i needed like that
[ __ ] is
way bigger than a hit record way bigger
hey sure have you ever got
uh um tweets
or comments on your instagram or
facebook or social media anywhere and
they say
i wish he was my dad all that all that
like
father you are my father like what they
say shane said that [ __ ]
real quick real quick everybody's
listening one of the reasons the timing
for this
these two have a double album at and i'm
excited about it because
there's been a kid that i've been really
giving love to for a long time called
guap dad4000
and they had a mod and i'm i'm about
that kid i think he's real real talent
um so hey go check that out download
stream however
however you put some coins in these
man's pockets talk to me about
verses talk to me about entrepreneurship
you know 40 you know i grew up in
the liquor and wine and spirits world
you know
immigrated from russia grew up in queens
my dad got a job as a stock boy in a
liquor store eventually had his own
small liquor store
and i i grew up in that place merchant
son i work 15 hours a day
you've really gone heavy i look at your
social you've gone heavy
into the spirits game i want to get a
little bit of that i really want to know
how the verses experience was
just for you like the enjoyment some fun
stories about it
how you feel to feel it went any [ __ ]
you want to talk to each other
whatever you guys want to take it
hey you know i'm gonna tell you
something man you know i'm
my granddaddy's always safe he said i'll
be in the car with him
because you know i had a paper route
when i was young you know i'm saying
with my granddaddy and uh granddad was
granddad's paper up but he'd pick me up
and he'd say he'd look at me because i
was hella quiet but i was
i was always observing and would not
soak up game like a beach towel
and one day he just uh boy you uh
cuz i was hella quiet just just me and
him in the car he just
you a heavy thinker huh
[Laughter]
i said yeah great daddy i am i am i am
you know
uh as i grew older i became a heavy
thinker but also a heavy drinker
crazy you know i'm not a i'm not a
i'm not an alcoholic i'm just a a a
serious social drinker so be
saying that um you know mom's you know
what i'm saying
she loved drinking like she drink you
know scotch all that stuff but that
wasn't her thing it was really
you know like wine my mom because my mom
worked two or three jobs she worked at
the little store around the corner
she worked at napa state hospital you
understand me we used to watch walls on
mayor island
you know people a lot of kids don't know
what washing walls is to prevent paint
having to paint your walls you watch
them you know so we just had to do that
you know as a kid on the weekends she
has so many jobs
worked at maggie's hamburgers i used to
throw salt on the floor
you know um and after we after our mop i
used to be in the back little kid little
youngster like 13 years old
back there mopping you know what i'm
saying whatever and uh you know
and and so on and so forth so anyway
she'll come home on a friday when i
interrupt you because i know my audience
short 40. how much do you think work
ethic
played into your success that's what did
it for me
because my mama i'm like i said i'm 95
95 cuz i was the oldest of four because
i'm listening to you
and like you know it's speaking to me
because it's i had a very similar
childhood like
you know shoveling like it's snowing
like crazy right here in new york right
now
i looked outside i'd be like i'd be
ringing door while everybody's sledding
i'd be ringing doorbells because my
parents weren't giving me money
come on man i worked at mickey d's i got
i worked at mickey d's i worked at
you know i said i haven't i worked at
vallejo neighborhood house and
paint out because real quick because i
think this will help people i'm sorry to
interrupt
you went through you guys have gone
through iconic music careers
i'm sure when i say to you think right
now about kids that you saw
come through in studio or writing who
were talented as [ __ ]
but they didn't have the work ethic and
you knew they had more talent
but nobody knows who they are sure now
you know in this game man
if you hang around long enough you
instantly
know that
success does not come to the talented
it does not like that's just that's a
gift you get
talent it's people who can surpass your
talented ass
just by mimicking talent they don't have
it they just could pretend it
but they put a hustle with it and they
[ __ ] you like how's this guy
he's clearly not as good as this guy how
did he get up there
he [ __ ] hit the right [ __ ] spots
and he [ __ ] did that [ __ ] so it's
like
i i just know man like like you talk
about your hustle
my hustle was always like
um to to to to um be productive every
day
so it's like i'm gonna wake up as a
child
as a teenager as an adult and whatever
the [ __ ] i'm doing when i wake up i'm
about to do a whole lot of [ __ ] to add
to that
today like it might be one thing it
might be 10 things
i'm going out there if i'm a kid i'm
leaving home
i'm going i'm getting active i'm going
to play a sport i'm going to [ __ ]
you were constantly in motion what yeah
i'm never [ __ ]
40. sure exotic pop right i see i
see you promote like do you bring the
same energy like is that a partnership
you have ownership is that is that
what's the story with that i'm doing
just a line of soda with them i mean we
when you get to this point in the game i
have not had to think about
you know uh like
little hustles and [ __ ] it's just [ __ ]
stays on the plate
the [ __ ] don't you get paid for the
legacy man you don't even
i'm making his brain i don't have this
one carried himself the way he carried
itself so many years
when you solid and you just you know you
got a great reputation
you know you help other people out he's
like i'm not gonna put myself in this
but this is
we the same me and him do the same [ __ ]
we [ __ ] with the young generation we
rock with them they rock with us we rock
with them we try to get love
you know so all of all those
opportunities come to you
so that being said with what you was
asking me yeah well how did i start
getting into
you know adult beverages you know
drinking wine
you know drinking wine my mama drunk
wine i sneak in her wine
for every now and then hello like the
gallon the big guy
you know i know carlo rossi that [ __ ]
was fake i was skinny
that [ __ ] was heavy for me those four
leaders four of them in that big ass box
that was worth it
gallo gallo is who influenced me just by
just gallow the whole story how they
started his family you know what i'm
saying
i got number love for gallo now i have
my own thing going you know what i'm
saying i'm
not never trying to compete with them i
just want a small
little more find a piece for a little
40.
cause they're the ones you know what i'm
saying so anyway
what's your favorite you've got so many
for you personally
i got i mean i don't know if y'all can
see it but this this is my number one
seller this right here is called
mango scado and they go crazy
my face my favorite my favorite social
literally some of my favorite social
media posts in the world and this is
what i do for a living
is when you're taking photos of huge
stacks in random liquor stores
because it takes me back to me
like i love it i love it he stays
where i know the owner just wanted to
meet 40 so he put 40 stacks on the
ground
because he wanted that photo you know i
went from wine
to selling cognac this is straight this
is a tycoon right yeah
this is the word you don't say this is
the word that i i've been screaming for
many years
you know i probably first displayed it
in like 1995 on a major way to intro
to in a major way my tycoon partner
player partners or whatever i said
you know what i'm saying but i've been
saying it for many moments way before
whoever you think made it up
40 40. before i before i let you go
because i'm going to be mad at myself
because i i blank a lot
cali mocha this is coca-cola hold on let
me put it in the screen
do your thing good let me know let me
back it up this is cola flavored
back it up i keep getting cocoa because
cola coca-cola got their own thing
i need to i need to know where your mind
is cola flavored
sprinkle me sugar tea i need to know
it's a [ __ ] banger i need to know
you need to know okay so check this out
you ready yeah all right
go give it all give me some game i'ma
give get some games so
my um my uh my sister sugar t
you know she was raised around you know
us three boys me d shot and uh mugsy
and be legit and uh all just all just
hogs we all hogs
i don't know if y'all know what hogs
mean but that's a that's an og word for
like a beast like
you know monsters like far from a sucker
you know what i'm saying
so she raised around real ones you know
what i'm saying so
she she she connected with uh you know
as as
she she was enthused she was she she
loved
folks that you know i'm saying that's
gained up so she ran across
my og partner which i looked i got
number love for to this day he go by the
name of james bailey stone i call him og
stump down
right one thing he did around around us
you know he he would he with us on
thanksgiving the whole whoa he already
are real folks he owe g though he hello
he owed it to me
you know what i'm saying and so he was
like you know faulty man i like to
i like to sprinkle the kids i like to
sprinkle it
you know i sprinkle them you know so you
know it's like really just really just
gaming them up
lacing them another word for lacing but
he say sprinkle me you know what i said
so one day man sugar tea in the studio
we have no idea
that we're going to make a song called
sprinkle me with mike mosley
and sam bostic we're in fairfield
california right next door to the i
think
next door to mcdonald's or somewhere
we're the fair field man
there we one of them studios and so we
um
so they made the beat and mike mosey
kept holland
yeah time or time of
saudi water sprinkle me man
you know this [ __ ] was saying
man like that sprinkled me mine
you know what i said you don't see it so
anyway
that just came naturally because it
sprinkled me that was in my head
was right there so you know she made it
official because that was her that was
her boyfriend at the time
you know saying like you know then it
just happened so we connected and did it
and it became
a major hit that we wasn't expecting but
he could come out of nowhere like a
contractual hit on your head bro
i'm telling you that's how hits go
that's how it is this is not a hit not
planned it's not playing like that
for us i mean for us the element of
surprise that's what a hit is it's the
element of surprise bro
they come out of neyward and that's what
happened actually
what what surprised the [ __ ] out of you
for you
and what because i think this helps a
lot we have a lot of youngsters who are
in music
listen to this what hit surprised you
you didn't expect it
and what song did you just [ __ ]
believe you hit up your man 40 you hit
up everybody around you're like wait
till this comes out but it didn't go
it didn't go you [ __ ] believed you
thought it was gonna be it
i'm just curious if when i ask you that
does anything stand out
on the second part man i really i don't
have um
like like your kids if you had a bunch
of kids i really don't have expectations
um i don't but early on i started
getting hit records without
expecting that so um
like it's too short to get ghetto you
know these records were going big and i
was like
i was happy with like regional success
and they just went big big big so
that was like i'm 20 years old 21 years
old
and it just that ever since then records
would come along
getting it cocktails these records would
just do what they do
and i kind of i had a career where my
underground songs
could rival the radio songs like in
terms of popularity
100 and driving sales so i would do a
concerts with other artists
and they might know one or two songs
would be like well i know that dude had
that one song i see this video
on yo mtv raps but then i'm singing 15
other songs they're like who the
[ __ ] is this and the crowd
knew it it was kind of weird it was kind
of like
you know it had that early it's like an
earlier version of mixtapes
so i have a song that is called
gangsters and strippers and this song
if you never heard it it would make you
like it and you would get a reaction it
gets a reaction out of everybody
because the first line of the song is
i gotta get a [ __ ] and get my dick
sucked and i repeat it
i repeat that four times before i even
bust one bar
gotta get a [ __ ] and get my dick sucked
i gotta get a [ __ ] and get it four
times
and now no matter who's in the crowd if
i got an old lady
i got an old lady she's like is he
[ __ ] saying this like you
is you can't not have a reaction so
the beat comes on this infection never
got a radio spin
never did a video to it i didn't even
give a [ __ ] about the song
it's called a kettle [ __ ] i did not
give two [ __ ] about this song
and when mtv had this show called um
sweet 16 and these teenagers were having
these sweet 16 parties
extravagant parties people around the
bay
and different places really around the
bay a lot were
doing these mimicking these mtv parties
and giving their kids
mercedes for their birthday and having
these big ass expensive parties but it
wasn't
wasn't on the tv show sure i i literally
i don't know if you're not gonna be able
to see it i have a very very very subtle
scar
on my pinky it's because me and my man
moose used to drive around campus
and when the line i'm too short [ __ ]
i'm the ladies pimp would come on i
would punch
my steering wheel because i would get so
hyped that one time i cut it so bad
it's like it's it's just it's just
so your voice is also
super like i i don't know this is just
such a pleasure because
these suburb kids upper class they
actually was did we did the party in
[ __ ] uh
san ramon danville and these [ __ ] um
these kids asked me to play this song
that i was like why would they want that
song that kids like that's the dirtiest
song
in the [ __ ] world i don't even know
that song
the kids ask for one specific song
gangsters and strippers
i sing this song for these teenagers and
the whole damn room knows the song word
for word
and i'm like crazy this is 20 something
years into my career
so i started experimenting with this
song that these one little group of
teenagers
asked me to play and everywhere i go
everybody know the [ __ ] words i'm
like
when and where and how did this [ __ ]
song become this
and i don't [ __ ] even i'm not even in
the loop it's real legend [ __ ] like
you know you've got these contemporary
artists who've got a lot like i always
like when sweetie samples you the other
day like i hear for the first time like
i wonder if people
that are 20 know the ogeness of this you
know like i always think about you know
this is what's fun about being 45 now
you know enough about the lineage yeah
and you see the recall
and you know when you have that kind of
ebbs and flows and it's
it's just it's just phenomenal what are
you guys thinking about going forward
like where's your
40 what's your mind on these days how
you think about 2021
let me just say this this you know on
twitter
twitter cracked me up because twitter
people kept telling me saying i see
someone on tic tac they say 40 a one hit
wonder
right and they just scratching my head
what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] was they born
at and what
what rock was they living under you know
what i'm saying
it's like you never know and i'll tell
you one hit wonder they said
choices
yeah that's a youngster he had to be
like probably 12
or 14 15 maybe younger maybe older but
he thought choices yup no no he thought
that was my only hit that i ever had out
of my 33 year
career 32 years 32 32 years
1988 32 i don't be i forget
anyway little ass kid knows e40 knows
when your songs that's
that's an amazing feat that's good
enough and i didn't get mad i don't even
know who the kid is
and some little kids were making the
dance routine up to blow the whistle
and not narrow one of them [ __ ]
could have been as old as the song
oh 100 that's that's the beauty of
getting into that classic zone
and still doing it and still having your
interest in different places
where are you with social media you too
what do you [ __ ] with what are you
confused by what do you like what do you
use
i'm i love
earl's a master he's going to tell you
he's a master but me i'm a realist
and i live with the um with the reality
that um
we believe that we use these tools in
certain ways but
this [ __ ] is using us it's pampering
that's for real but
you gotta fit
that [ __ ] in the money
i'm just saying man i'm not really
talking about i'm not talking about the
way you can milk
immediately i'm talking about what you
give to it and what it gets from you
that's what i'm talking about that's
true
that's very true i just have to clarify
i'm right with you pippin you know what
i said but i understand what you're
saying
you you know hey but i'm saying how you
know
[ __ ] ain't involved in the [ __ ]
that you understand me
that they think is pimping you you know
what i'm saying yeah
backdoor investor all that [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah no it's a back doors
by the way by the way
hold on one second hold on one second
hold on it's my show
hold on one second baby hold on i just
want to say one thing
there's always a given truth about what
i'm saying i will i will of course i
will i'm so glad you're here
hello the whole your entire career has
been a give and take though short right
there's always a platform
there's always someone in your pockets
there's always a venue that has the
attention
there's always a platform what's
beautiful about this
is what what you're able to do by
building demand
you know there's no gatekeepers somebody
was the gatekeeper of yo mtv raps and
decided
here it's direct to consumer that [ __ ]
matters 40 take it away
so here's the deal we nowadays a lot of
our
um i would say um our culture hip-hop
as well you know just this this our
culture
we are i've been on this page from day
one
i was a young mustache like entrepreneur
i've been on that page
ownership independent all that [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
now it's the new sexy to be independent
to own [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying no this thing
in the third that's good
so you work your way you climb your way
up the ladder
you know because you know us first of
all you understand as an
african-american
you know we were we were we were stopped
in the middle of our we couldn't they
didn't want us to learn how to read or
write or nothing bro
so we're making like highs and doing
some catching up and we're doing [ __ ]
pretty good
you know what i'm saying to be to to be
held back from
like you get your [ __ ] balls cut off
and [ __ ] like that hung and all kind of
[ __ ]
if you get caught learning how to read
come on man what kind of [ __ ] is that
so all i'm saying is we are we are
making great progress
as a people you know what i'm saying so
i try to have i try to support all
black businesses and this ain't no no
old like we i'm far from racist
you know what i'm saying bro you listen
i love i love humans i love people
i think that's beautiful i think like i
laugh when people get upset
like that's what people do that's why
you know polish people support politics
like jewish people support jewish like
that's a good thing why is that bad
especially when you especially when you
had it as bad as us and nobody's
everybody had it bad but i'm saying you
know us we we got to start looking into
us like bro we all the same team that's
enough money out there for everybody
let's get this
break you know abundance once you start
realizing there's abundance
you can really do something definitely
so you know you got people in the
background that's in social media on the
tuck that people don't realize
that's in the background of some of
these social media companies
that that has part of that you know what
i'm saying and and ain't i'm not just
saying me
you know i'm in there too you know i'm
saying i just don't scream everything
you know what i said i don't see i don't
tell everything you know what i'm saying
like you would never think that e40 is
in
50 startup companies you know what i'm
saying you would never think that you
you might not even know because a lot of
people don't know i'm very you know i'm
very smart i'm sharpening the porcupine
spine
i'm very sharp you know i'm just a comm
i'm just calm
i'm just like a personality i'm like uh
what makes the best rapper
too short you're one of the greatest
rappers of all time not because of what
you stand for what you spit
the game that you spit but you bring
humor to the game
we bring humor to the to real life
situations how about that
they'll make the dopest rappers by the
way by the way
by the way short brings humor to
difficult situations
you know when when i listen to short as
a kid you can imagine
i and i didn't grow up in a wealthy area
so i didn't have that but i just still
had
people like short [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy
like short was bringing real crazy
lyrics you know
and like whoever heard it a friend's mom
the neighbor
like a teacher like it was real real
real aggressive and i remember
you know thinking about the judgment
because
i was very you know i was born in russia
where
jewish was kind of like black in america
right both my grandfather spent real
time in jail just for being jewish
anti-semitism is crazy in europe not
like we don't have that in the u.s this
is more of a race
country but i remember thinking
you're making judgment on this dude and
all the music i was listening to
i'm like but you don't know this is like
an escape like
the humor is like you people use humor
to cope
short was putting out humor about like
situations like those are those truths
yeah what's that brother nancy reagan
suck my mother yeah
exactly and like what people you know
now it was the president
[ __ ] like you gonna put that
[ __ ] out and what people
hey hey
listen people people people in
revisionary history understand at the
time
like people you know now we have the 40
years of retrospective of like drug laws
and things of that nature
this is why art listen you guys are
artists
i i always tell people like you've
you've got to take a step back you're
coming from a very narrow angle and a
lot of these conversations
take a step back here's something man do
you remember when they were steamrolling
hip-hop cassette tapes of course they
were
in the history of any of this [ __ ] that
anybody ever dropped my name
in any of those we have a problem with
this list of artists why
he had the nastiest mouth of all time
why short
i don't know why do you have a sense
uh for the most part i would think the
main ingredient was i was not a
mainstream
artist even though i had mainstream
numbers
and they were listening to all these
artists who had
publicists and who were blaspheming
correct and were selling they were
actually marketing
their controversy i was i was just doing
it
we didn't drive didn't job didn't have
to market too short
and they didn't they didn't have to
market the image of too short or e40
none of us they we we really were um
spice one
ugk even you talked about krs
one quest we all marketed ourselves
in job records you know they just they
just all they had to do is put the
machine to work
to get it in the right outlets we were
[ __ ] the phenomenal list of artists
that's why they signed us to
distribution deals and so so on and so
forth compared
to being that we have built in fan base
our fan base is
so loyal high five what about high five
is that jive had signed compare them to
the artist that
def jam has signed at the same time the
dev jam
artists are huge they got this marketing
tactic where their
everything is they push them everywhere
[ __ ] make a video
everywhere jive these [ __ ] artists
are like timeless
he's talking terrorist one e40 [ __ ]
nice too short you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] uh
uh try quest i'm talking [ __ ] ugk
like they had a [ __ ] roster
that stands timeless as we said
was it a leo
listen [ __ ] man i could do this all day
i gotta i gotta wrap
give me give me a little give some game
to these youngsters
what do you got what's your parting
shots legends i got one
mount westmore that's where the game is
at this is like
you got this is a chance for you to get
you got
four legendary you know about man
westmore
you know about it
mount westmore is a
you could call it a super group that
i'm fine with that but mount westmore is
a
corporation it's an llc formed by oh
this is the snoop and ice cube thing
this is youtube
right yeah i got you i got you i know
what you guys are doing i'm sorry
basically we started off
making a few songs we we're like four
very intelligent guys who didn't take 10
seconds into the venture to go
well let's license this let's branch out
that let's do this deal
and this [ __ ] turns into a multi-fucking
million dollar deal
instantly just for joining for us and
leverage and take it from there you guys
are [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] avenger
that [ __ ]
hey listen bro they're the avengers in
real life you know
something real i'm being that's it it's
about the super friends you know we old
school you say
that's right the rings and shirts
i'm old too you know
it's like you know you got four some of
your favorite rappers four of
some of your favorite iconic rappers
especially and we from the coast we
always was
us each individual all our voices poke
out like nipples
snoop dogg you ain't gonna see his face
oh that's snoop wrapping
too short oh you ain't gotta even see
his face that's too short rap
ice cube oh that's ice cube rapping e40
you know i poke out like nipples all of
us do you you we don't you know what i'm
saying
you got four you know you got some of
the coldest rappers
and you got two of them from up top
northern california
run up they just might do you and you
got them you understand me from southern
california
you understand me where to do some harm
to you you know what i'm saying so
it's like you got all these great
rappers four of them and we all get
along and we're not
and we're like good people prior to the
priority
coming together we're all ready for
years
probably the past eight ten years we've
been doing
all these west coast festivals uh every
[ __ ] two three times a year we
haven't
out in the midwest they want to see but
they've been a virgin
music so that's not here that's right
just like he said 10 like the last 10
years
it's just been like it's been um you
know at one time
they stopped saying this [ __ ] too short
listen i'm gonna say this they stop
saying this
they stopped saying oh man he's 40 years
old why are you rapping they don't do
that no more
nobody because they turn 40 real quick
your favorite real quick real quick feel
me
don't say that [ __ ] it's a young
genre you know it's you know when i look
at all y'all now i'm like
oh [ __ ] because when i was a teenager
i'm like
yo these parents really [ __ ] with the
rolling stones still
and they get crunk like when they go
like parents would come back from
rolling stones giant stadium i'd be like
yo
they really [ __ ] threw down tonight
and that's and that's what's hap and now
i understand it because that was a young
genre rock and roll
hip hop came 30 20 years whatever math
is
that's why we say gary we say why why
can rock
rockers can do it all day they can rock
all day
how come rappers can't rap all day they
just came over
they just came a little earlier listen i
can't wait to be 80
being in a little lounge hearing you
guys spit some poems
so the future is we did not do an album
together we recorded
about 40 40 50 songs
and this is going to be a continuous
thing
it's gonna be a volume one two three
four five type of situation
they're probably gonna come out pretty
quick and it's not just one album as
many of them
and we got blaps and we and we
what we're doing is exactly what y'all
think we're doing
we got that happy medium you know we
gonna want y'all want y'all gonna want
to hear some songs where
it's like the sound that y'all grew up
on just like when i listen to earth 105.
i think they don't want them to do no
new schoolwork when if i need them to
have a happy medium earth one and five
yeah so we for you but we got that new
school too
because you understand me we rock with
the new school too so we got that
we're not going overboard with it you
feel what i'm saying hello
so the partnerships the you know the
merch
the the license of the image wherever it
may go
the movie the [ __ ] movie good for you
the tours for you man i i cheer for you
i cheer you can't call
four different managers and book
us on a tour you gotta call us now
from now on i love it good for you
fellas i appreciate your time
i'd cheer for you heavy keep keep
pushing for it keep showing all the
labels let them
soak them all in short for it thank you
so much
thank you very much appreciate it health
and happiness hit me anytime anything i
can help you with
god bless you thank you for everything
of course all right guys
bye-bye youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you